we have this conversation about whether
slavery should be taught in schools and
so on and my answer to that is yes the
problem is we don't teach about slavery
in schools what we teach about is the
transatlantic slave trade and this way
of looking at the world is is quite
silly to me it's sort of like evaluating
whether a sprinter is fast or slow
without comparing them to anybody else
you can't do it you have to understand
what was happening everywhere else at
the same time and I talk about my own
family history of being slaves in Russia
I talk about what was happening in my
country what was happening in Africa
when the evil Western colonialists
arrived and by the way the
transatlantic's later it was absolutely
Evil by the standards of the modern day
but it wasn't as bad as the uh the
trans-saharan slave trade which was
conducted mainly by Muslim and Arab
traders
didn't last as long didn't take as many
lives didn't have such a high death rate
and slavery was continued continually
practiced around the world much later
and only ended by the way thanks to the
Western Colonial powers
putting a lot of effort and a lot of
money into it does that excuse the
transatlantic slave trade of course not
but it gives you the context to
understand that the Western powers are
and remain some of the most Progressive
tolerant societies that have ever been
created and our crimes which are many
there is no doubt there are many should
be seen in the context of that in the
context of the fact that other great
civilizations and Empires around the
world were doing the exact same things
and worse at the same time and we ended
it we stopped it the British Empire was
committed to abolishing slave trade and
slavery all over the world from Brazil
through Africa Egypt India Malaysia
and elsewhere 450 years that's a big
commitment and it cost the end of
slavery Remains the greatest moral
achievement of the West it was a